hey guys I'm Ryan Wright today is gonna
be a special medal your solid video I'll
be catching up I show dad know your salt
three crab battle and then I finally saw
the phantom pain red band trailer Kazuma
Kenway has been harassing my [ __ ] for
like six solid months now wanting me to
watch this video so this video is gonna
be mainly for you my friend because I've
gotten a couple of other requests but
you are the only one that has really
managed to whip out that [ __ ] and just
shove it right into my ass to the point
where I am recording a video so let's do
this Metal Gear Solid Echo I think it's
a music video
echo echo
I
to
amaura randomly cut I was saying this
game was cool
it's my turn to protect you
that's a cool like it's cool like
trailer that spoils way too much for you
if you haven't seen Metal Gear Solid or
played the games but no that was a cool
video I thought the music choice was
really interesting I was thinking of
like Christian rock groups for a second
I guess the songs at first I was like
this song kinda doesn't really fit the
Metal Gear Solid vibe but once you kind
of let go with that and then you just
accept the song for what it is the
images do become moving along with it
you know like the editing sequences are
really good people who edit these videos
don't get enough credit it's hard to
match all this and find all the right
clips and then be able to tell the story
cuz he's taking footage from a lot of
the Metal Gear Solid games he's trying
to tell one whole story by inner lapping
with footage from one from two and so on
and so forth it's pretty impressive what
this person was able to put together
it's interesting that they heard this
song and they thought Metal Gear Solid
footage would go along well with it I
wouldn't have thought that but no that
was a good video thanks kazoom I ignore
2zu yeah I forgot Kenway this video was
just for you it's over now